it's time for
pop quiz
all right
hope you've been paying attention lisa
bacon hi
hi
all right
are you ready oh my god i can still feel
that frowny on my forehead all right
lisa you've been paying attention to the
show right i have okay great well we
have three questions and if you answer
all of them correctly you're gonna win
one thousand dollars
all right i'm so excited for you good
luck our first question is what is the
habit sterling k brown just can't break
i will chew nails from time to time he
bit his nails yeah
okay yes weirdly the left pinky all
right question number two you're almost
there what dish did joey king make this
is my my cousin's famous couple
google
yes
yes
you are one question away from one
thousand dollars
okay our third question is what famous
friend do i and esther have in common
hey i just showed adam sandler your
stand-up and he
said he wants to produce your special oh
my god
[Music]
congratulations
congratulations congratulations thank
you thank you
thousand dollars leave the bacon just
brought home the bacon
i know brah i'm proud of you that was
great yeah yeah good emily i'm all right
congratulations and thank you guys so
much for coming out today and we really
do make this show for you
just take the good energy from today
with you it is made for you thank you so
much everybody
[Music]
you